[Music]
John schaffner designed the most famous
New York City apartment of all time
except it only had three walls and no
ceiling and it wasn't actually in New
York designed a set of friends John is a
production designer and John has worked
on a lot of show I've done a 44 series
and sixty eight pilots dharman Greg the
drew Carey Show two and a Half Men Big
Bang Theory and most notably friends
when I get assigned a new show I do what
is called a sketch model in white paper
and you hold it up and you close one eye
and you squint and you can see just what
the camera is gonna see when we were
presenting friends I presented a white
model and the producer looked at it and
said well now what are we gonna do about
color what do you want to do and I said
I think we should take the sad Purple's
everybody was really anxious about
nobody likes change until I painted the
little model purple color is really
important in terms of establishing the
show identity when you switch to friends
you saw that it was purple and you stay
tuned
one of the responsibilities of a
production designer is to look into the
future if you can we put a door all the
way up this hallway and we really didn't
say where it went to I said why don't we
just wait and see where the story is
taken so all of a sudden years into the
show we've never seen this door open
they do an entire episode about this was
Monica's messy closet oh my god
I definitely think that the coffeehouse
on friends sort of influence our culture
where people like to meet and hang
around thank you and now of course 25
years later there's a coffee house on
every corner and I'm surprised how many
of them have overstuffed chairs do in
the pilot the moment when Rachel walks
through the door and the wedding dress
is a pivotal moment we made a decision
to put the door up here on a diagonal
she bucks POW through those doors and
straight to the camera and everybody had
to like physically turn and look this is
everybody this is Chandler and Phoebe
and Joey and you remember my brother
Ross sure who knew that that was gonna
be the beginning of 10 years of a number
one show on television
[Music]
audiences relate to sitcoms because once
you get to know the characters you
become invested in their story so it's
easy to turn on and watch an episode of
friends it's a comfort coming back to
visit with these characters and be with
them for that half hour I'm so lucky I
got to design friends
[Music]
when these music requests come in for
Rick and Morty I never know what to
expect I I need to know what a frog
planets instruments would sound like
it's like an intergalactic race riot but
it's a love story
I need a royal March for an insect
species that thinks it's koalas I write
all the music for Rick and Morty in fact
my names in the credits we'll hold on
[Music]
[Music]
take for example in season 1 episode 2 I
had to score this alien bondage dream
sequence took a while to figure it out
but once I realized I could use this
Gregorian chant as a background element
really came together sooner the episode
gets schwifty that alien band that gets
annihilated I did make it sound like
they were playing instruments from
another planet using only instruments
from earth so I used a bunch of
percussion instruments from all over the
world
my favorite song I wrote for Rick and
Morty was goodbye moon men which is kind
of a David Bowie thing and actually if
you listen closely you can hear me
singing background vocals here I'll
prove it goodbye moon man you say
goodbye
man
I left a couple of musical Easter eggs
in the show and I'll tell you about one
of them in season one I wrote a song
called human music and you can hear it
in season 2 in the lobby of Jerry
daycare not everything's purposeful
though the theme song I actually wrote
for another show that didn't get picked
up we use it as temporary music for Rick
and Morty and everyone liked it so we
just decided to keep it so I've been
with Rick and Morty since before the
beginning and I've seen all sorts of
music requests come in and sometimes it
gets a little weird but you know I like
weird and I wouldn't have it any other
way
Ryan I really wanted you a rap about the
flu and I can you do it this tempo
[Music]
whatever that tempo is and give me five
versions
[Music]
Michell Krugman created the show
Clarissa explains it all yeah I did and
some other classics yeah I created Baron
the big blue house and I worked on
Rugrats ren and stimpy Rocko but I loved
Clarissa so we came out here to talk
about it and learn some things about the
show that we probably didn't know cool
here we go the latter was I think about
four rungs or something like that it was
like about
maybe this high and Sam had a crouched
down underneath the window and go like a
mime you know coming up every time and
he had to slam it on there and we had to
get that guitar sting and of course and
when they built the set you could see in
the pilot we eventually fix this right
then the pilot you could see through the
window and see the floor of the studio I
[Music]
banned purple I would never give a
reason and I kind of rationalize it a
little bit by saying you know I'm trying
to appeal the boys and girls and I said
well it's got to be all pink and blue
you know we got to use those as our main
colors and purple throws that off
[ __ ] you know complete [ __ ]
right they just ignored me after a while
[Music]
well I can't really tell you is the
problem with that I've never told
anybody even Melissa I had the most
amazing writers I had Suzanne Collins
who wrote Hunger Games
Alexei Young who was one of the main
writers on friends Nina Bieber wrote
plays and wrote Daria I mean these
writers you know all went on to do like
amazing stuff you know if you're like 26
to 36 you know almost universally if I
say I created Clarissa explains it all
they scream like a fourteen-year-old
girl and they say that's my childhood
you made my childhood and those are the
words everybody says it's like my
career's 30 years younger than I am you
know which I love it's super satisfying
it's completely wonderful
[Music]
for 31 years I have been acting in major
motion pictures in TV series but you may
not recognize my face I'm Doug Jones I
am an actor I got into acting out of a
need almost to be validated and it was
at Ball State University that I
discovered the art of mime it's a very
visual form of communication and
entertainment little did I know that
this would be early training ground for
the career that I was going to have lay
in later years I had no idea after
moving out to Hollywood land in March of
1985 and thinking okay now's the time to
pursue this acting thing
my fourth booking was for a McDonald's
campaign that got me kind of hooked into
oh he's that tall skinny guy who wears
stuff and moves well in it and doesn't
complain while doing so my first feature
film was Batman Returns I got that
audition because of my contorted legs
and the credits that says thin clown
which kind of kind of self descriptive
isn't it I have been in over 150
productions that would include
everything from feature films like hocus
pocus
Hellboy 1 Hellboy 2 the Golden Army the
fawn in Pan's Labyrinth was a page
turning career moment for me
Fantastic Four rise of the Silver Surfer
I played the Silver Surfer a Star Trek
discovery as commander slew and most
recently the shape of water so when
asked about how long is the makeup take
it depending on the creature it can be
anything from
a suit going on and zipping up the back
or a makeup that is applied you from
head to toe for instance as commander
surreal and Star Trek discovery it's
around two hours a day which is
mercifully short flip-side would be an
Abe Sapien from the Hellboy movies so
that's one of the longer ones that took
seven hours a day wearing rubber bits
that gets everything that you think it
would be it is how does he want it to be
it is heavier than you want it to be
it's more isolating than you want it to
be you can't always make it access to
your naughty bits to go pee if you want
why go through all of this makeup
application the time that it takes you
can create monsters with the effects now
I think people like to watch other
people so even if that person is playing
a monster they want to connect with a
human's interpretation and performance
of that monster it's old-school cinema
magic I kind of get the best of both
worlds when it comes to being a public
celebrity the bigger movies I've been in
the bigger things that I'm known for I
look like this and them on the street
I'm just the tall skinny guy that's a
gift now that I'm in a movie like the
shape of water with 13 Oscar nominations
I'm getting recognized in public a
little bit more but it's still not to
the point where I where I have people
hiding in my bushes hoping to get a
snapshot at me topless
that's not happen again
you
[Music]